siamo percorso iniziamo ovviamente dal
cenacolo poco distante da qui siamo
nell'effettuare 60 media grazie ma
ovviamente non parleremo del codice da
vinci del cenacolo in stai ma
dell'immaginario cioè che cos'è
l'immagine porterà un polacco al mio
mulino c'è guarderò dell'immagine antica
questa qua la prima immagine nel
cenacolo fatto un affresco completamente
diversa da quella che abbiamo qui a
milano forse la prima immagine legata al
tema che ovviamente un esempio questo è
un manoscritto va bene così vedete una
struttura piatta non c'è prospettiva
giuda è messa al di qui della della
tavola
quindi è un manoscritto appunto
dell'anno mille abbiamo percorso già un
po di secoli qua la stessa più o meno
cosa con con cristo e giuda ben
evidenziato in questo appiattimento
stabilito proprio da
questo straordinario questo è una
vetrata di chartres in cui vediamo
sempre giù da fuori ma giovanni come
evangelicamente sul costato di cristo
non potete come si evolve l'immaginario
dello stesso passo evangelico questo
giotto questo giotto che già modifica
quindi immagina il testo in modo diverso
vediamo sempre giovani su cristo e giuda
che il vince la semplice quindi stiamo
guardando l'antico proprio l'altro ieri
questo e duccio più o meno parte della
modifica delle aureole una struttura
classica diciamo cioè viene
rappresentato sempre più o meno nello
stesso stile
qua iniziano a cambiare siamo vicini
avvicinandoci al cenacolo
siamo in una grandiosa prospettiva
rinascimentale del castagno appunto
cinzia giù da sempre all'antico modo
medievale con giovanni vicino a cristo
però è un altro spettiva
straordinariamente rinascimentale è
legata a uno spazio pieno di germe di
marni qua siamo nella cappella sistina
siamo veramente in una sontuosità non
solo di luogo proprio di via di spazio
però su stili antichi come disposizioni
degli dei protagonisti di questa vicenda
qua invece siamo al nostro diciamo
oggetto dei desideri che appunto è un po
un lavoro che stiamo facendo insieme
perché poi ognuno nell'immagine nella
l'idea di che si può fare partiamo da
questa può essere usato questa immagine
poteva essere usato a qualcosa
qualcos'altro ovviamente siamo a milano
siamo uno dei capolavori milanesi ma il
gioco è sempre uguale qui
ci sono due cose interessanti almeno ci
sono tantissime ma questa la spazialità
leonardo crea una una prospettiva
accellerata un effetto 3d che non era
mai stato dato è magnifico immaginate
per un visitatore dell'inizio del
cinquecento guardare questa questa
infinita che linee ancora resa in
gigantesca da queste tre finestre verso
l'infinito francia scoprirlo quando
arrivammo in alto ma il me lo porto a
casano un attimo e soprattutto il tema
cioè non parla di tutto quello che
succede in quella santissima notte ma il
nel refettorio dove tutti i giorni
domenica ne mangiavano cioè nico di una
delle parole di cristo uno di voi mi sta
tradendo mi tradirà e c'è un proprio una
teatralità
vérité le mani perché questo questo
supporto vedete quanto cosa succede che
un po inquietante da due volte a
mangiare ricordai vedere queste immagini
che chi evoca qualcos'altro
cosa succede dal
1498 ai giorni nostri
qua niente siamo nell'inizio dei miei ma
siamo in latitudine nobel ma importante
sapere ciò che c'era
perché ovviamente ho portato esempi non
troppo come dire autoreferenziali nella
dimostrazione però anche al nord non era
ancora arrivato il c'era internet invece
dure che aveva conosciuto leonardo poco
dopo
ovviamente lui è un grandissimo non è
che lo copia però già un movimento
un'apertura una prospettiva
qui al wine
soprattutto nelle mani in qualcosa e
soprattutto in queste tre aperture
ovviamente avrà visto qualcosa la
reinterpreta guardate come viene
elaborato a livello mentale l'immagine
nel corso dei secoli poi un lavoro che
sta facendo adesso è
ormai
abbastanza chiaro riferimento ognuno poi
si trova in particolare perché ognuna
avrebbe bisogno di qua siamo negli anni
venti a 500 è troppo ricevute le mani a
destra la struttura e tre aperture cosa
ovviamente diversa è il richiamo l'ico
questo è un tiziano prima maniera che
all'apertura ma abbastanza diverso un
tiziano della maturità
straordinariamente simile ma e morirà
nel 76 ma guardate il movimento le mani
giovanni lì però giuda comunque insieme
agli altri siamo tutti i traditori
non si può più
fare a meno di questa opprimente
immagine per effettuare di santa maria
delle grazie
del tè voi guardate le aperture dietro
insomma
poco piazza è
non volevo far ridere ma sa bene
rubens
ovviamente lui è un grande qua a questo
tipo di briolo messo per dire si sa
benissimo però ciclismo
questo qua è stata vari parigi
qua proprio felician 21 imi autori
preferiti e idea addirittura c'è la
piegatura attiva e passiva della
tovaglia stirata del cenacolo
complimenti
maraglino
tiepolo tiepolo invece ovviamente c'è
l'apertura e senso della spazialità
della commensalità però ovviamente
diciamo che ci sono degli aspetti molto
vicini al cenacolo però proprio tra le
righe non è questo il luogo per qua
proprio siamo totalmente a seconda metà
dell'ottocento
vogliono a san pietroburgo e cioè i
russi vogliono fare una loro immagine di
un testo evangelico ortodosso e quindi
si stop si stavano completamente dal
prototipo vince giustamente e quindi vi
ho portato anche il contro esempio che
ma che male non fa
questo è un nord
non c'è quasi nulla del cenacolo c'è
proprio la voglia di rompere con la
classicità
anche se questo ha senso della
convivialità
rimane però ovviamente qui sarebbe un po
ardito anche quindi l'esercizio e non
trovarlo in ogni momento è
calma un attimo
fatti riportati apposta back wine
spencer che non c'entra nulla si ritorna
a giovanni sul costato di cristo però
c'è l'apertura questo senso della tavola
e non la divisione congiunga
ormai questo prototipo è entrato anche
nella modernità nella contemporaneità la
infetta e non se le può fare più o meno
da lì che sembra anche lì ma c'è proprio
la completamente diverso questo senso
proprio dell'eucaristia di qui leonardo
non voleva dare assolutamente ma c'è
senso dell'infinito
ovviamente mi fa sempre un po po sopra
le righe e da lì però ne ha una
sicuramente un sentore
questo interessante perché esatto questo
budget che ai musei vaticani è
esattamente un ricordo non vuole imitare
leonardo e da quello che c'è stato prima
con judas il cui nome compare in alto al
di qua della tavola come lo succedeva a
chartres come succedeva nei manoscritti
che abbiamo visto
guardate questo è un regalo questo è un
buon ul che non ha nel film che ha vinto
nel 61 festival di cannes e so che siamo
recenti dalle fasi della classe guardate
imita esattamente è una celebrazione del
circolo di la nato anche l'arte un altro
tipo di alte non ne può fare a meno
e il cenacolo senza i commensali questo
critico in cui ovviamente ormai leonardo
diventa il padre a cui non si riesce più
a
warhol che dedica a cena ancora da vinci
proprio una serie non notevolissima
guardate anche questa di studi
fotografici e di serigrafia su tela
paterson cambia completamente la
modernità proprio una parete con i nomi
interessante interessate ovviamente non
mi sembra che ci siano grandi affinità
però
ma non vogliamo trovarle
questa questo che è un po irriverente è
un cenacolo in cui sembra che non ci
siano finita invece ce ne sono molte
volte per la divisione degli apostoli e
per quelle tre aperture che inutile se
anche se siamo un sotto skyn su borgo di
new york
ahimè ricorda il refettorio di santa ma
nega e poteva far due però è sempre più
uguale notre questa è l'ultima vi faccio
vedere una pubblicità che ovviamente e
dissacrante perché ricorda talmente il
cenacolo che le amiche è stata proibita
in italia perché considerata blasfema
anche perchè confidava di coral francesi
benissimo
abbiamo finito voi vi siete fatti un po
il filo avete visto un po questo è un
gioco che potete fare a casa con gli
amici mettendo le figurine e aprendo i
libri di storia dell'auto ovviamente una
provocazione
abbiamo fatto il cenacolo ma potevamo
fare qualsiasi altra cosa è un modo di
per dirvi banalmente diverse cose una
banalmente che il moderno
e leggibile la sua completezza solo se
c'è l'antico e quindi dobbiamo per forza
addirittura abbiamo vedere lo ieri ma
anche l'altro ieri per essere proprio
tranquilli e sereni e prenderlo nella
sua interezza un altro discorso
interessante che è il discorso degli
archetipi
affrontato young in modo cioè noi
viviamo gli artigli dentro di noi nel
nostro nostro più male nostra anima
abbiamo degli alticcio delle immagini
che che ci rendiamo consapevole non
consapevoli ovviamente le alte tipi
iniziano da anni dal mito
ma io sto parlando di archetipi
immaginativi cioè nella creazione di
nuove immagini
il cenacolo è un capolavoro non solo per
la maestria per chi l'ha fatto per la
fisiognomica per tutto quanto è stato
scritto ma perché un archetipo cioè
seduce è un'energia
che ovviamente a cui si deve per forza
fare i conti è un padre e un nonno qui
tutti gli autori ma non solo gli autori
che creano le immagini ma noi fruitori
abbiamo unico di queste immagini il
problema in un mondo così
pieno di immagini è difficile creare
archetipi nuovi per il futuro perché
ovviamente sono stati già fatti ma
comunque siamo a studiare quelli antichi
per capire dove possiamo posizionarci
perché creare archetipi e creare nuovi
linguaggi nelle comunicazioni un nuovo
senso di spazialità mentali di libertà
interiore
queste immani al cenacolo vediamo un in
immagine fissa su un 1 ma un'energia una
storia è una poesia
un'ultima cosa è partito veramente
l'acqua al mio mulino
onestamente sì parliamo tanto di
contemporaneità
abbiamo visto quanto serve per
per il domani
comprenderà il antico quasi una banalità
sto dicendo
però
mi piace pensare che queste pitture
questi capolavori queste uniche immagini
che non vanno via come internet come
youtube ma rimangono i fisse aiuto noi a
ad arricchirci come diceva sì moderna
grande filosofo e novecento la bellezza
di quelle immagini erode la mediocrità
alla bruttezza un altro autore
dell'ottocento diceva io non vado nei
musei per conoscere gli antichi maestri
ma per conoscere un milione stesso ecco
il messaggio non è partire dal cenacolo
fare questa cosa il messaggio è che
quelle immagini servono noi oggi
a vivere a superare difficoltà ad andare
in un museo affermarsi in mezz'ora
davanti un grande quadro e l'energia di
quelle forme di quei colori di quella
sapienza ci aiuta a vivere oggi e forse
con un animo più sereno
vedremo il futuro